ja öffentlich kämpft die neue dgb chefin
jasmin fach chemie dafür dass
angestellte mehr geld bekommen doch auch
selbst kassierte deutschlands oberste
gewerkschafterin gerne ab und zwar
doppeltes gehalt familie sitzt im
bundestag als spd abgeordnete und würde
jetzt zu neuen dgb chefin gewählt beides
geht nicht das weiß natürlich auch frau
fanny und will daher zum 30 juni ihr
bundestagsmandat niederlegen doch bis
dahin bekommt sie doppeltes gehalt mehr
als 20.000 euro die opposition ist
empört
ja nicht nur die bei uns im studio ist
jetzt der leiter der parlamentsredaktion
ralf schuler an reifen muss sagen das
ist ja gleich ein doppelter aufreger
doppeltes gehalt und eigentlich kämpft
man dafür dass die menschen mehr
verdienen wie ist das überhaupt der star
cher war ja gut wenn man zynisch wäre
würde man sagen sie kämpft dafür dass
die menschen mehr verdienen und fängt
schon mal bei sehen aber so ist es ja
nicht und man sollte auch nicht nichts
böses unterstellen sie hat vor der wahl
zur dgb chefin angekündigt dass sie ihr
bundestagsmandat
niederlegen wird und deshalb haben wir
nachgefragt sie ist jetzt dgb chef in
seinem 90 was ist jetzt mit dem mandat
und da kriegt so einfach ja sie habe am
ersten juni eine einen termin bei der
bundestagspräsidentin und wurde dann zum
30 juni das mandate niederlegen das
seltsam so selbst am verdruckst und
verzögert und natürlich gibt es weiter
geld und zwar auf beiden seiten und das
hat der dgb auch eingeräumt dass beide
gehälter gezahlt werden und dann wird
eben das dgb gehalt als neben ein kunft
für das bundestagsmandat öffentlich
registriert mit anderen worten ja sie
nimmt uns jeweils bus anzeigen das ist
das eine problem das andere problem ist
nach den neuen verschärften
transparenzregeln des bundestages die
nach der masken affäre eingeführt wurden
darf kein bezahlter lobbyist im
bundestag sitzen und ein mandat haben
einen gewerkschafter ist ein bezahlter
lobbyist das beißt sich irgendwie das
heißt noch mal einmal zusammenfasst und
was hätte sie anders machen müssen
man kann ein mandat wie sie es
angekündigt hat nicht ruhen lassen man
kann aber ganz schnell und
unproblematisch darauf verzichten eine
einfache erklärung an die
bundestagspräsidentin hiermit lege ich
mein mandat nieder und am nächsten tag
wäre sie das mandat los gewesen und
hätte keine
konflikte gegeben mit mandat und der
bezahlten lobbytätigkeit die spd ist es
gewesen die jahrelang immer auf einen
lobby-register gedrungen hat die immer
gegen lobbyisten im bundestag gewettert
hat aber es gibt keine guten und keine
schlechten lobbyisten ein lobbyist für
die arbeitnehmer interessen ist aller
ehren wert aber nicht im bundestag denn
ein dgb-chef muss auch im bundestag und
in der bundesregierung ganz klar für
seine mandanten für seine mitglieder
werben und das verträgt sich nicht mit
der volksvertretung für alle ganz
einfache regel also gewalt zum zum dgb
chefin danach niederlegung des amtes das
wäre die saubere lösung gewesen geht
davon aus dass er jetzt vielleicht
diesen schritt noch gehen wird dass ihr
amt niederlegen wird und diese doppel
bezahlung zu vermeiden oder ist das dann
doch etwas was man ganz gerne noch
annimmt und seid also sagen es läuft die
tendenz geht in der politik häufig dazu
dinge einfach auszusitzen und zu warten
das finde ich in diesem falle schwierig
denn sie hat auch gesagt sie ließe ihr
amt ruhen sie bekommt aber im monat 4000
euro steuerfreie aufwandsentschädigung
den aufwand hat sie ja nicht bei einem
ruhenden amt also wenigstens das könnte
sie spenden oder irgendwie anderweitig
zurückzahlen das problem ist dass ein
mandat ein sehr hohes rechtsgut ist und
man kann es nur niederlegen oder
annehmen und die saubere lösung wäre es
jetzt niederzulegen man kommt auch mit
dem guten gehalt eines dgb chefs prima
über die runden sollte